[Music]
let's go to Hartford and talk to Robert
what's up
Robert hey Dr John how's it going
partying man what are you up
to not much uh just excited for this
call I'm excited to have you brother
what's up thank you I appreciate it um
so I'm calling because I wanted to get
some advice on how to deal with my
social anxiety oo good good question man
all right
um so I want to can I walk through it a
little bit and teach a little bit about
social anxiety and then we can walk
through your particular situation of
course yeah all right so social anxiety
I want people to think about it as your
body's telling you that you're not safe
because you're constantly under
surveillance you're being judged people
are examining you people are watching
you right in the nerd world we call this
a negative examination the world is
looking at you and they don't like what
they see and you're never going to
measure up to a particular situation and
in some case uh like with social anxiety
disorder you can never measure up with
other people and that makes being around
other people ex
exhausting and excruciating so am I with
you there does that does that ring true
yeah definitely yeah okay and over time
you just get sick of being exhausted all
the time and so you end up slowly
withdrawing or finding ways around
groups of people people or dealing with
people altogether even if you have a a
skill set in an area or a passion in an
area it's not worth um feeling like
you're on display and that everyone's
judging that display um and sometimes
that judgment's real like U giving a
public speech or um I know you're a
physician right and you got to meet in
front of a bunch of other people
sometimes it's not it's a feeling that
everybody's watching you judging your
appearance or the way you walk or the
size of your nose or how close together
your eyes are whatever right and then
tell me if I'm on to something here
Robert then over time you start getting
anxious about being
anxious yeah yeah definitely and then do
you have what I call um I I call it the
pad the post anxiety drama so you are
anxious about this event so anxious I'm
so anxious you go to the event you think
everybody's watching everybody's
listening that was such a stupid thing
to say and then the next 6 hours 8 hours
are just consumed with replaying and you
judging basically like a film of what
just took
place yeah yeah like I shouldn't have
said that I can't believe I said that I
think they don't like me I think that
one person was really annoyed by me all
that does that sound
right yeah and then there's also the
shame of like not wanting to be the
person who cares about what people think
so that's like another layer on top of
everything okay and there's there's
shame underneath that too there's a
couple studies out that link uh social
anxiety disorder and shame so Landing
with
you um we have a pregame analysis we
have the actual ah and then the postgame
analysis and during the pregame analysis
the pregame anxiety there's that shame
like I don't even care what they think
but your body's like you better and then
afterwards there's that shame I didn't
measure up
I feel it I could tell yeah so let me
ask you this growing up who watched you
or critiqued every move or made a
negative analysis of you on a regular
basis do you have somebody in mind or a
group of people in
mind um I mean that's an interesting
question because I grew up in a very
Like Loving household I would say I
never really had to worry about whether
or not my parents cared about me or
loved me so
it I would I was always kind of like an
outsider at school okay and so I would
say if it was anywhere it would most
likely kind of like be from school let
me go one layer deeper um and this is
not an indictment of how much your
parents loved you or an indictment of
how good your quote unquote your parents
were
right
um what was the attention to detail like
meaning in our house everybody's shirt
has tucked in there's a smudge on that
shoe go change your shoes fix your hair
this is ridiculous did anybody
withhold um almost a sense
of don't say that because Dad's gonna
get really mad if you say
that a sense of holding up the the the
the
family yeah that's a good question um
thinking about it I would say maybe that
existed like with my mom and
um like with her like religious beliefs
kind of um this is did it happen at a
religious institution like this is how
we act when we go in here no she's kind
of like anti-
institution stay at home and read the
Bible kind of thing okay so yeah your
body didn't have a picture of Mom and
Dad going out and cutting it up with
other
people never I mean no I I don't really
have any memories of them being together
they got divorced when I was like four
okay and
um yeah they yeah I don't really have
any uh image of like what that would
look like yeah so just an interesting
this and again this is about curiosity
not judgment we're not mad yeah I just
want to ask myself and you can do this
off the call right and maybe spend some
time writing it down but I just want to
ask ask
myself did I get any messages either
explicit like hey those people will hurt
you or implicit like no crowds that's
where crazy people are it's we're not
driving after dark that's that's when
the drunks are out like we're like those
kind of messages that we get that
slowly close the doors to outside people
and then if you don't have a model my
dad is a cut up he's a funny guy and my
mom was always they always had people
over growing up and so I saw
interactions I saw goofiness I saw
people poking fun at each other I saw
disagreements and so then when I saw
that and experienced it at school I had
a context for it right yeah if you don't
have a context for it and then a group
of people are like oh you're an idiot
and there's no your nervous system can
shut your body down right especially
coming out of a divorce person yeah it
it it hits anyway I think those are
interesting things to flesh out but it
doesn't solve it giv some context but it
doesn't solve where you happen to be
right now so let me ask you this how
does social anxiety play out in your
everyday life now as an
adult so um it kind of manifests in like
my body and like I have all these like
physiological kind of symptoms when I'm
um in groups of people like that don't
really pose a threat but my body will
react as if it is like a major threat
like my heart will start to race and
I'll lose control of my breathing or I
will um like my voice will start to
shake and I don't want to present that
anxiousness to people so I hide from it
and then that avoidance leads to
isolation and loneliness and um and
you've probably heard me talk on the
show about it when when your body feels
anxious about something and you avoid
that thing that it made you anxious
about
it actually reinforces that anxiety
alarm makes it stronger right because it
got because it won right it got what it
wanted so the next time you're on people
it's going to it's going to ring earlier
and it's going to ring
louder and then you're going to avoid
them again and then it's be like yes
safe again right and all the time you me
like you become really lonely and
isolated yeah yeah man all right so let
me ask you
this what do you think other people are
going to find out
um probably
that those those symptoms that I
mentioned prob no beneath the symptoms
we're not going to blame the symptoms
those are the alarms what's underneath
that what are they going to find
out that I'm not comfortable with who I
am or I'm not confident or I'm I don't
believe in myself okay underneath that
thing what are you not confident about
that they're going to find out
that's a good question it's like when
you peel the layers back it's like what
is even there
to feel that anxious about um well it's
it's they're going to find I'm not
confident okay yeah about what that you
can't and I'm just gonna like if I'm
playing with a group of guitarists that
are really
good I get anxious cuz I'm not great I'm
really good at rhythm guitar and I'm
really good at running around on stage
when it comes to playing the weed Le
lead stuff I'm not that great and but I
can I can fake it but when I'm around a
group of guitarists that are really good
like my buddy Nolan my buddy will like
I'm around those guys I start getting a
little angsty because they're going to
find out I'm not very confident because
underneath that they're going to find
that I'm not very
good and if I've attached I'm only worth
hanging out because I'm this
good then my body's going to sell me
alarms because I'm about to get excluded
I'm about to get kicked out of the
group right right so underneath your
lack of confidence underneath your lack
of what are what are you afraid they're
going to find out about
you or let me ask it another way what is
so bad about you that if they knew it
they would be like oh my
gosh I I really don't know I'll be
honest I've tried to do a lot of
reflection and figure that out myself
but like it's hard to it's hard to
really know if I'm honest
okay what are you so nervous they're
going to
see
um weakness I guess I guess that's what
those symptoms to
me uh exhibit I guess so do you see how
this is a
ghost yeah yeah you're
nervous that they're going to see that
you're
nervous so your body gets nervous about
them seeing that you're going to be
nervous right the whole thing is a ghost
right it's a ghost it's very very real
and yet it's not
there my guess is there's something
deeper though okay I've just done this
long
enough like the old the great bery Brown
says shame eats secrets for breakfast so
my guess is there's some sort of secret
some sort of something that you are
afraid they're going to find
out and you don't have to say that out
loud here and you may not even know on
the top of your head what that off the
top of your head what that
is but your body is trying to protect
you from them for some reason okay so
here's what we're going to do and and
there's another question I want you to
ponder what is literally very
specifically what is the worst that can
happen right because when you walk down
that road usually it's oh nothing now if
you have social anxiety and you the
thought of public speaking terrifies you
and your boss says hey you got to give
the presentation at the board meeting
there's a consequence to that right you
can get fired or they may be like oh my
gosh you blew it that's for real hanging
out with friends on the
weekend may be less for real right so
it's going to be context dependent but
asking yourself what do you think people
are going to find out what am I nervous
for them to see and what is the worst
thing that can happen literally very
specifically are they really going to
leave me good for them get out of my
life I don't want them
anyway what is it about me that my body
is trying to protect them from finding
out about and I think that's a question
worthy of exploration for all of us what
is my body trying to tell me and so
here's the thing um these are little
bits of CBT cognitive behavioral therapy
little bits of exposure therapy there's
some very clear clinical practices here
if you want to Robert to go sit down
with a counselor there's very clear
protocols for healing from this okay um
okay there is none zero there is no path
void of
discomfort okay exposure therapy is
about slowly opening the door a little
bit wider and a little bit wider and a
little bit
wider um if you have a phobia of snakes
what they'll do in the first couple of
sessions you'll talk about snakes then
in one of the sessions you'll draw a
snake then in the next session you'll
look at pictures of snakes at the end
you're going to hold this alive snake
right but we're going to slowly teach
our body we're okay here and we're okay
here we're okay here social anxiety will
have similar things but I here's what I
want you to do I want you to go today
and I want you to spend a little bit too
much money on it okay I want you to get
a journal of some sort and I want you to
call it a nonsense
Journal okay or a alarm system Journal
all right and I want you to write down
those thoughts as they start to spin
this will be a huge pain in the butt at
the beginning okay just know that up
front it's super inconvenient it's like
counting calories the first time it's
annoying and you have to recalibrate
your system I want you to write these
things down and begin to ask all right
I'm going to meet with three friends my
body's already spinning up what are you
scared
of of looking nervous nous well I feel
nervous so they're going to have to see
that eventually you may get to walking
in and being like guys I'm super nervous
to even be here I'm going to pull that
bullet right out of the gun before it
even goes off right but we're not there
yet but I want you to begin to write
down those things and I want you to be
really honest what is your body so
scared for other people to see because
here's what I think I think you're a
pretty good guy thank you and I think
you bring a lot to an organization I
think you bring a lot to a group of
friends
and I think somewhere along the way your
body picked up some messages that aren't
true that other people aren't safe other
people are what's going to harm and hurt
you so you got to avoid them at all
costs and at the same time that's like
depriving your body of oxygen because we
have to have other people to survive so
we're going to do that and then the
second thing is we're going to Outsource
some of this to one or two friends that
we really trust do you have that in your
life I have my brother um and that's
kind of it is he
trustworthy yeah okay I'm going to just
put this out there on the show because
um because it is what it is I've talked
a little bit about having body
dysmorphia most of my life like being
weirded out by like never being in shape
enough or never having big enough
muscles or whatever the problem is
seeing something in a mirror that other
people don't see and so I know sometimes
when that flares up when I'm exhausted
when I haven't been taking care of
myself I'll put a t-shirt on and it will
won't feel right and I'll look over at
my wife and say is this shirt okay to go
outside and she'll look at me and say
yes and I have outsourced that to her I
trust her implicitly and I begin to feel
what it feels
like because my body's saying it's not
you shouldn't wear this shouldn't wear
this it's too tight it's too small don't
wear this don't wear this and she said
you look great and so I'm going to begin
to practice feeling what it feels like
when it actually looks great and
sometimes occasionally she'll say no not
today and I don't get my feeling certain
I don't get mad I trust her and I'll
just I'll go change my shirt you see
what I'm saying I begin to Outsource
those things that are highly charged
highly emotional in me and so maybe
texting your brother before you go meet
with a group of
friends say am I am I crazy no man go
have fun all right cool I feel a little
bit nutty right now but I trust him I
trust him so I'm gonna go hang out and
what we're going to start doing is
practicing feeling that discomfort and
can I tell you one big spoiler alert
Secret
yeah no one's watching
you yeah I know I know yeah everybody's
so obsessed with themselves and how they
feel and how they look and what they
just said and what their hair is
doing nobody's watching you and if
anybody is watching you they're watching
you out of Defense not offense they're
watching you to make themselves feel
better and God bless
them see what I'm saying yeah yeah
I want you to protect against that
shame that I shouldn't be feeling
nervous go with your body on it cuz
maybe you should maybe your body's
working just right for how it was raised
how it was trained growing
up maybe that maybe that feeling is
right
cool that kept us safe when we were
younger that helped us navigate a
divorce that helped us navigate a mom
who kind of closed the door to the
outside world whatever that you it it
helped us navigate a tough School
situation like you experienced it's
doing its job I'm not going to feel
ashamed about that my body's working
just as it should but I got to teach you
something new because I want friends and
I want laughter I want Community I want
goofiness I want silliness I want ride
or dies I want people in my life that
means I'm have to be uncomfortable for a
season While I Work Into the Storm head
into the anxiety here um I do again
reach out to our friends at betterhelp
um reach out to a local counselor this
is there is some very
um um concrete research backed protocols
for dealing with social anxiety and you
can work through it if you choose to but
I also think you can start with a
journal with a close friend or two or a
brother in your case and some very
intentional
huh what's my body trying to protect me
from right now what am I so scared
they're going to find
out often the answer is going to be met
with a big smile nothing I'm Robert
I'm going to go hang out and have
fun I love you brother thank you for
calling